cracking down on auto theft that is the  mission behind metro's task force called  viper  and the team made a big bust last week  taking down a large  chop shop and a car theft operation  right here in clark county but it didn't  stop there  while everything may have been based  here the crime spanned  30 states and more than 30 arrests were  made 18 of them here locally  and officers didn't just find stolen  cars  seven firearms including assault rifles  thousands of rounds of ammunition  three and a half pounds of  methamphetamine  approximately 2 500 pills of fentanyl  six and a half pounds of marijuana  concentrate  twenty grams of heroin over fifteen  thousand dollars seized in u.s currency  so you can hear there that was quite the  bus they made metro says  it's proud to get auto theft rings under  control because they're often fronts for  much more dangerous crimes  the suspects have more than 150 charges  between them  kristen